اجتماع طال انتظاره بين وزير الصحه
استقبالي ومسؤولي نقابه الصحه لحل النزاع
اضرابات اعضائها بسبب الاجور اجتماع حمل
امال التجنب المزيد من الاضطرابات في
خدمات الصحه الوطنيه التي تعاني من ضغط
شديد غير مسبوق وسط التكهن بسداد الدفعه
نقديه لمره واحده الى المطربين ترتبط
بالانتاجيه
وان المحادثات جاريه وفيما يتعلق بالدفع
يجب ان يجري تلك المحادثات على اساس ما هو
في متناول الجميع وما هو معقول
لكن يبدو ان هذه المفاوضات التعثرت في اول
اجتماع بين الطرفين بحسب مسؤول النقابه
لانهاء موجه الاضرابات
الحكومه فرصه اخرى لتصحيح هذا الامر لقد
جئنا الى هنا بحسن نيه ما يريدون التحدث
عنه والانتاجيه عندما يعمل اعضاءنا لمده
18 ساعه كيف يمكنك ان تصبح اكثر انتاجيه
لا اعرف
شهر يناير عاده ما تكون فيه خدمات الصحه
الوطنيه تحت ضغط كبير بسبب الامراض
الشتويه المتزايده الى جانب معالجه
الامراض الاخرى خصوصا ان قطاع الصحه بحاجه
الى ملئ اكثر من 130,000 وظيفه فيما اعلنت
وزاره الصحه انها ستنقل الاف المرضى الى
دور الرعايه لتوفير المزيد من الاسره في
المستشفيات
فشل المفاوضه بين الحكومه والنقابه يعيد
جدوله اضراباته في قطاع الصحه بدءا من هذا
الاسبوع وقد تكون الاكبر على الاطلاق التي
تشهده بريطانيا وفقا النقابه اذا لم يحصل
اعضائها على زياده اجرهم تعكس غلاء
المعيشه مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن